what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
dare I say Detective Comics can do no
wrong in in DC it's insane how good
everything is in Detective Comics I've
been a Batman fan for a long time I
haven't read as often as I should really
Scott Snyder is new 52 Batman is kind of
what pulled me in and then from there
was just keeping tabs on the crazy thing
was that you know picking up with a new
52 it was a fresh start in some ways but
it wasn't in others and all these people
when I was going through forints you
were talking about Batman incorporated
different things like that I was like
okay maybe I should go back and read all
that stuff you know I never got too
in-depth into it but I always loved the
mythology behind the Batman concept and
going into DC rebirth you know with the
Batman line up stories Detective Comics
I kind of see the Detective Comics is a
little bit better than Batman just
because of the fact that instead of it
just being Bruce Wayne and focusing you
know largely on his character I think of
the idea of like the bat family you know
basically like a reinvigorated Batman
Incorporated on a much much smaller
scale it's more interesting more
appealing to me and one of the standout
characters in Detective Comics in my
mind has been bat woman Kate came but
the crazy thing about this you know at
least as you know the way this was
written by tinium is that it looks like
he's going back and retconning a lot of
things um those are the guys who were
really really well versed and that woman
feel free to correct me if I'm wrong on
this because again I'm coming into this
doing as much research as I could
weathers there's for everything I found
there was something else telling me that
I was wrong so we went okay what's wrong
and what's right so I'm kind of I'm
gonna look to you guys
you-you-you bat woman fans you I'm gonna
look to you guys to help me out on this
one but as far as I've been able to tell
when that woman was was introduced into
the the new cookie - it wasn't her first
appearance she was a character that it
showed up I think it's part of 52 weeks
now the Batwoman concept had been around
forever it been around since the 1960s I
think she was one of she was one of the
handful of characters that was made and
an attempt to keep Batman comics
relevant in the face of cancellation
like that might Batgirl Barbara Gordon I
think that woman I think back then was
Cathy Kane that they were all you know
created for the purpose of trying to
bolster Batman's range and keep it more
interested as you know as well as draw
in a lot of female readers when it came
to the new 52
unlike Batman where he was grounded he
was more realistic he fought in Gotham
City Kate Cain dealt a lot with
supernatural things but like all the
other DC characters she got a zero issue
now for those the guys who don't know
when DC first launched today 52 was all
just a known number one everybody gets
number ones and here is where the
characters stand right now here's what
Superman is doing right now here's what
Batman the Green Lantern here's what all
these guys are doing right now with
regards to you know the zero issue a
year after the new 52 started DC said
everybody gets zero issues and the zero
issues went back and they basically
cover their backstories now with Batman
it was actually like zero year and it
was a story arc it was a multi comic
story because Batman was the
highest-selling comic the DC had at the
time alongside Green Lantern it made
sense that it would really just sort of
explode and get it's great big huge
story arc but but the character of K
Kane there were a lot of things that was
that were being focused on with regards
to her character's run you know focusing
on her sexuality trying to beat her up
but also keep her removed from Batman
but the sake of trying to build our
character and allow her to stand on her
own two feet
the issue with this is that most people
don't really like the idea of
supernatural Batman stories some do but
we saw a lot of supernatural Batman
stories you know after crisis on
Infinite Earths and legends of the Dark
Knight which were designed to fill in
the gaps between Batman year one and
when Batman became like an actual
superhero and so because of that the
series ran for respectable you know
40-something issues but ultimately it
was canceled and so because of that we
basically get this sort of rebirth you
know with her character in Detective
Comics and what seems to be happening is
again it's really you know Tinian coming
along and saying okay at least one I can
tell everything after zero the over zero
issue her origin story is non-existent
instead it seems to just kind of pick up
right after that and well well flush
this out as we go along again I'm
looking to you guys who are Batwoman
fans to uh you know correct me if I'm
wrong on this just somebody posted a
comment before as if we would wait for
you to tell us it's okay for us to
correct you what what happens here is we
initially pick up in the younger days of
kaykai not super young but when she
basically first becomes bat woman now
keep in mind she's being trained by her
father and for those of you guys were
new to my channel who were just not
picking up which Detective Comics
K Tina's father in DC rebirth was
basically the head of a group called
colony and colony was a very like
paramilitary organization that was
looking to the idea of Batman and said
this guy's a one-man army
he basically set everything up around
him to be a one-man army if we take that
from him if we basically conquer Batman
we take everything from them we have an
army composed of people who were all
one-man armies as well as basically like
we would have an army of Batman you know
that was really the basis of the
storylines the Batman we would have an
army of Batman and we
be able to just eliminate crime all
across Gotham but the issue was that I
guess a bigger picture that Tinian was
hinting at was that you know the colony
would look to dominating the planet
Earth or dominating the country or
something like that
there was no definitive insight it was
just kind of left open-ended like they
will go on to do bad things with the
technology of that name and so because
of that um Kate Ames father was
basically defeated and he's been held
prisoner in the belfry the base of
operations for for the bat family ever
since so because of that transitioning
back to these early days Kate Cain being
trained by her father is designed by the
purpose of honing her skills but also
for her to infiltrate the back family
and that's a crazy thing about this is
because you know prior to all this and
her traditional version story she picked
up the bat woman mantle because she just
want to be a superhero you know she'd
been kicked out of West Point the
military academy she had basically
fallen down every crappy hole until she
essentially hit the bottom and then once
she got there much like Bruce Wayne when
he lost his parents
she found hope in the symbol of a bat
and decided to take on the mantle a bat
woman kind of removing herself from
Bruce Wayne and going on to to fight her
own battles but with this it seems like
almost immediately after she adopts the
mantle of that woman her father says
we're going to train you and we're going
to bring you into the to the colony and
we're going to basically make you a
force the biggest difference between
Batwoman and batman however are their
motives are their drives of their
desires batman looks to stop crime in
Gotham City that woman looks to stop war
because you know she was raised in a
family of people who had been killed in
action so because of that you know she
looks at a much much bigger picture but
the other half of this is that she's
very Damian Wayne esque in terms of how
she conduct herself she's not ruthless
like Damian Wayne but she is willing to
kill and because of that it kind of puts
her at odds with Bruce Wayne and puts
her at odds with Batman in terms of how
the two of them conduct business with
one another now but regards to this
story right here you know kind of moving
back to this through these particular
events her father again plays a very
very crucial role in her life because
for her you know for Kate Kane this is
huge issue of betrayal you know that her
father trained her to be somebody who
was very capable not only that because
of the fact that in Ian's kind of going
back and changing a lot of the things in
the past there seem to be some
unresolved issues here that on the
surface that woman feels like she's
betrayed when intrude it seems like they
might be working together it seems like
there might be a much darker story going
on under the under the the whole theme
here in terms of the fact that she is
basically a spy inside the bat family
working you know working with her father
we don't exactly know how far
are this how far this river flows but
what ends up happening is she's
basically pulled you by Batman to the
quarantine zone and Gotham City under
Argus now again Argus you know the
Advanced Research Group uniting
super-human is basically a government
station organization for the purpose of
looking at your I guess working
alongside different superheroes and kind
of being like this liaison sort of
speaking of providing momento providing
an information that they need the issue
here is that following the events of
night of the monster man of course where
Hugo Strange had created a monster venom
that literally transform people into
monsters where these are all you know
these are all beings were defeated the
issue that that Argost faces is that
Hugo Strange as monster venom can be
weaponized that essentially somebody
could take that venom they could travel
to some of the locations they could sell
it to a government that government could
use on its soldiers and suddenly they've
got an army of near unstoppable monsters
now the cool thing about this is if
Tinian kind of plays the fast and loose
with the superhero community right like
I mean our gut reaction would be well if
there are more than army of monsters in
the world well then Superman we're just
taking out like Superman would just
defeat all of us but what Tinian does
this is kind of something that we have
to do whenever we go through and we read
that that comic we have to read it
within the confines of Batman itself and
so you know for Bruce way it is oh my
god we'd have an army of monsters
running around it's not to say that
Justice League wouldn't get involved
it's just in the immediate the world
would devolve into absolute pandemonium
and absolute chaos if an army of
monsters were to descend onto a major
city like Metropolis not only that
because of the fact that Gotham girl who
is for all intents and purposes a female
version of Superman with similar
abilities similar capabilities I
wouldn't say is is wrong his Superman
but because of the fact that she is a
metahuman and she was transformed into a
monster that the monster venom takes no
prisoners when it differentiates between
you know who's a metahuman and who's not
everybody gets infected equally and so
Superman could be turned into a monster
you know and it would make things
infinitely worse but the fact remains
here that Argus basically says with
somebody or with people presumably going
in and stealing this stuff the only
person they've actually seen doing it is
some unknown being now of course we
don't know who this guy is right off the
top of our head but Argus essentially
said you've got to find this guy you got
to track him down and you got to get the
serum back because if it's being sold on
the black market it could lead to
absolute catastrophe and so what happens
is we pick up with this unknown man
arriving in the belfry with the
intention of breaking out the father of
K King no breaking Colonel Kane out not
only that we also learn a little bit
more about the military structure of the
colony and the reason why I say this to
guess what a colony first popped up in
Detective Comics vol 1 that's part of DC
Weaver the first story arc for Detective
Comics rebirth it really just seemed to
be like you had you know Colonel Kane
and then he just had a whole bunch of
soldiers and all they did was just take
orders that's what made it you know
seems so Suzhou paramilitary but what we
learn is that there is a structure you
know there's a hierarchy there it's
limited but there is a hierarchy much
like you know the Nova Corps in regards
to the Marvel Comics photographs of the
colony you've got the guy who runs the
whole show then you've got colony Prime
he basically got the best of the colony
soldiers and then you have all the other
colony soldiers and so this guy colony
parm is names actually Simon Samuel is
again here to basically break out
Colonel Kane and then for the two of
them to use this monster serum to
presumably you know turn their own
soldiers in the monsters you know wage
war against Batman defeat him once too
for all take his stuff and then go
through and complete the plan that they
were looking to complete in the first
arc of Detective Comics the issue here
is it almost immediately after this
happens we're met with the arrival of
that woman and Batman this is kind of a
cool thing here because again you know
tinium does not involve any of the other
bat family I mean there's there's no one
else here you know there's no one else
in this location no one's there it's
basically just that woman and Batman now
from here what we do is we actually jump
back a little bit when that woman was
being trained by her father
Ras cake came was being trained by her
father one of the first things was you
have to understand how Batman works you
have to be able to track him down you
have to be able to harness every step
that's the only way you're gonna be able
to even get close to him what she's also
been doing if she's been using
surveillance footage to monitor how he
fights and this is one of the things
that she does you know she tells her dad
she says hey look I've been monitoring
Batman's fighting style I've been
monitoring how he acts I've been
monitoring how he functions he's not
military he wasn't trained by the US
military he was trained by something
else now we know that Batman's training
is not from one definitive source Batman
was trained with a multitude of
different sources you know and it's a
combination of different martial arts
styles that he's learned over the years
as well as most likely some method of
street fighting that he's picked up
along the way when he's encountered
individuals who were able to counter his
fighting styles and so because of this
in the middle of her conversations and
the middle of her analyzing Batman's
fighting style she suddenly met with the
arrival of Batman himself now this is
why I say that Tinian seems to be going
back and changing a lot of things
because in the initial conflict she
immediately fires off the shot and hits
him in the leg
uh the issue with this is that of course
Batman doesn't really seem to be saged
but instead he starts having a
conversation with her he says what's
your deal you know why are you following
me around because that's a cool thing
you know tinya is like look this is
Batman he's not a fool
you know Batman knows that she's
following him around this girl is
basically untrained you know she's raw
talent just waiting to be sculpted into
something you know dangerous and deadly
and because of that Batman sees
potential in her and he basically shows
this potential when he says I don't know
what it is you do but you do not fight
the way I do I don't use guns you know
it'd be easy for Batman just start
shooting up Gotham City right I mean
just roll into Arkham Asylum with an m60
and just start spraying down everybody
that he comes across you know just
killing off all the bad guys that would
be easy but that man's like we don't
take the easy road we take the hard road
one because there's a larger payoff and
two because no one is without hope but
at the same time that woman says well
that's fine but that's your style like
you you wage war against crime I wage
war against war you know I'm here to
basically in humanity's fighting you
know I would rather see a peaceful
planet than a peaceful Gotham City and
so bad that essentially runs over a lot
of her backstory says hey look you know
you are your cake King you know you're
the daughter of Colonel Jacob Kane she's
the granddaughter of Katherine Hamilton
Kane she's basically heir to a fortune
you know she lost her sister she lost
her mother it's really just kind of
pinyon saying hey here's where we stand
with the character right now allowing us
to sort of go through her origin and
pick what parts are still in continuity
because of that he basically says look
you're going to be on a short leash now
his Batman didn't want her monitoring
him at all he would shut everything down
he probably would have activated some
EMT who knows but he would have shut it
all down instead he says if you get in
my way I will bring this famine so it's
basically him giving her permission you
can keep tabs on me you can watch you
can learn but I do not want you getting
in my way and so he's essentially saying
look you've got talent you've you've got
talent here
you've got skills you've got drives
you've got Direction you've got
motivation ambition all that stuff you
know because you have everything you
need to become something great watch and
learn you know and that's the coolest
thing about all this it's because
whether or not Batman says it this is
when he first took her on as a protege
you know now again we also learned that
the entire basis behind all this is
again for her to basically infiltrate
the bat family not only that this is
really you know the this is her father
talking to Samuel you know again this is
in the past
two years prior to what was going on
right now and he says look she needs to
be able to infiltrate that man to figure
out how he works to figure out how he
functions to basically use this
technology in a way that can benefit us
as the colony so that we can we can
weaponize the Batman ideology and we can
use all that technology for our own
benefit but the issue that they have the
concern they have here is that because
of everything that Kate's been through
she's not really easy to manipulate so
much as it would be easy for her to fall
prey to Batman's
ideology to the notion that there is a
better way you know to become very Dick
Grayson like in that capacity and
because of that their concern is that
issue falls too deep they have to pull
her out the problem is that button
trying to came around to the point where
they were ready to pull her out her
father decided to invade the belfry and
then it all came crashing down when he
was taking prisoners so jumping back to
the current moment right now jumping
back to the present day again we have
Simon Samuels going out against Batman
this is kind of a cool thing here is
because Tinian toys with us a little bit
you know he presents this guy Sammy on
Simon Samuels and says this guy's wildly
capable this guy is super solid he's a
great fighter he's going toe to toe a
bad man you know he's going toe to toe
with that woman not only that the the
technology the various resources that
they have allow Simon to turn the
defenses of the belfry against that
woman and Batman was like damn this
guy's one step ahead of him every every
step along the way like he's always
right around the corner as soon as they
get there he's around the next corner
you know the guy's always ahead of the
game but so because now the question is
like is Kenyon setting him up to be a
legit villain it's Tinian setting him up
to be like the next Bing in or something
like that you know is it going to be one
of these instances you know where he's
always taking potshots to the bass
family and it's the one guy they
considered to be more dangerous than
almost anybody else but all of this
comes to a head when he arrives at the
barracks and he's talking to you
hurricane is a I'm here to get you out
what Colonel Kane's responses look I
don't know what you're talking about
you're not here you're not in the Brig
yeah I don't know where you are but
you're not in the Brig well this is when
we learn that the entire thing was Rouge
that that woman in Batman knew that that
someone was their assignment or somebody
like him would be coming they knew that
somebody would show up for the purpose
of trying to grab Colonel game because
he's too important because he knows so
much because he's so capable and because
of that they basically had everything
set in motion the idea of Samuel you
know Simon Samuel taking over their
defenses that was their mistake he was a
ruse you know they allow that to happen
you know at the same time because of the
fact that Simon have been taunting that
woman and saying hey look you know
you're untrained you know
you're not a legitimate fighter here
you're someone who just doesn't really
have what it takes to be a real soldier
she basically turns the tables on them
and says look you're in the mud room
you're basically in a room that's
designed to create projections to create
Holograms it was designed by Tim Drake
for the purpose of allowing people to
train and because of that you basically
fallen prey to the most obvious trick
figure not actually where you think you
are
it's tinium sitting down and saying look
this guy's a great fighter he's not that
great you know he's not a very smart
thinker he's not the brains behind the
operation he's capable but that woman
that one is better and that's the kind
of the crazy thing because it's
basically kenan saying here's not far
kate kane has to come you know what she
first started out she was basically a
fresh recruit you know she was being
taken under her under her father's link
her father was like I'm going to train
you to be someone capable and the first
thing you're going to do is try to track
down a Batman between the time that she
served its part of the bat family up
until now she's learned so much she's so
capable you know not only that the fact
that she's here alongside Batman means
that Batman trust her more than anybody
else now of course there's a reason
behind this and we'll get to that here
in a second but in the midst of this you
know someone basically pulls out all the
softy says okay fine yeah he grabs this
monster venom injection self and turns
into a giant monster the issue is that
Simeon sets this up for Simon to be a
recurring character in the sense that he
basically just jumped out a window and
takes off and that's that you know
that's s that's really the end of the
whole thing now of course we also had
that woman shooting him with a shotgun
you know and that's where the difference
is between that woman and in Batman
different instance the Batman's like I
would never use guns not only that in
the conversation between the two of them
Cait Cain says after the first time that
we met and I shot you in the light when
you told me that I could follow you or I
could keep an eye but if I got in your
way you'd shut it all down when I shot
you on the leg my cousin Bruce Wayne
called me to a meeting we ended up
having lunch and I noticed he had a limp
and that's when I figured out that
Batman is Bruce Wayne that's what I
learned the two of you are one and the
same and that's what led into her
becoming part of the bat family that's
what led into her becoming you know
taking on this major role as part of the
bat family but that's also the reason
why Batman trusts her so much because
she's basically family you know she's
the closest thing he has to a brother or
sister or something like that she's
nothing like a brother or sister but you
know in terms of blood relation
she's the closest thing he has I guess
aside from Damian Wayne and so because
of that what we end up doing is we pick
up with her speaking with her father you
know and this is the first time that
she's done this since he was taken
prisoners but she
used to speak to him you know almost
like you is ashamed or disappointed of
them or something along those lines but
while her father cracks a few jokes here
and there in the end he basically says
there's a war coming there is a war that
is going to be coming here and you are
the only one out there capable of doing
what needs to be done to fight it off
you're the only member in this back
family that's willing to kill people and
so because of that the question is are
you ready to fight this war are you
ready to do what needs to be done and
she says yes and so he says okay let's
get started now this is Tinian kind of
leaving things ambiguous because we
don't know what direction things are
going to go in now I mean of course that
woman rebirth number one will officially
pick up with all of us and so we don't
know exactly what game is being played
here we don't know if you know she's
basically going to be spying on her
father on behalf of Batman we don't know
if she's going to be working against
Batman while secretly working for her
father we don't know if she's going to
be a double agent betrayed them both we
have no idea what's going to be going on
with her but what I do know is I'm
excited as hell to read that story but
when I'm being said guys if you are new
here to comics explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button become part of
the raw pork you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you on Leonard
you